change never comes easy no one said it
would in times of adversity you must ask
yourself Who am I where do I belong
you see nothing is given in this world
and wise men know that with great glory
[ __ ] Accra Feist so it begs the
question what are you willing to
sacrifice for your greatness nothing
damn it
I want to eat whatever the [ __ ] I want
and be skinny
I will do whatever it takes to make sure
I don't have to work out ever again
this is my last cheat meal before I
change my life and maybe this one or
this one
actually I forgot
you
iron is forced in flames through
adversity your shoe colors will show
you
you can't do it alone you feed for
inspiration blood sweat tears triumph
I had an early lunch okay
bad habits take time to change there are
no quick solutions for a lifelong
problem you have to be your own
motivation you are the steel that will
sharpen your own resolve fight endure
persevere conquer there is no room for
your excuses
so what do you say
[Music]